Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
J’étais en train d’écrire mon texte
pour ce TEDx,
quand je réalise
que mon logiciel Word souligne
le mot « métavers »,
il ne le reconnaît pas.
Alors je me dis : « Hou la, je m’apprête
à parler à des centaines de personnes
d’un mot qui n’existe pas.
Rebecca, est-ce que c’est vraiment
ce que tu souhaites
pour ton début de carrière
comme jeune chercheuse ? »
En effet, je suis enseignante
chercheuse en informatique.
Moi qui aime le théâtre,
j’endosse dans ma vie plusieurs rôles.
Un jour, je mets ma blouse blanche
et j’effectue des recherches
dans un laboratoire.
L’autre, je transmets mes connaissances
aux étudiants.
Aujourd’hui, j’enfile encore un autre
costume en venant vous parler du métavers.
Je n’ai pas forcément
la tenue stéréotypée du geek.
Je n’ai pas de lunettes carrées,
de chemise à carreaux.
En plus, je suis une femme.
Pour couronner le tout, je n’étais même
pas née quand le métavers a été inventé.
Eh oui, contre les idées reçues,
le métavers n’est pas un terme nouveau.
Il a été introduit en 92
par Neil Stephenson,
un auteur de science-fiction.
En fait, au même titre
que beaucoup d’avancées scientifiques,
le métavers est un concept
qui naît de la science-fiction
et que beaucoup utilisent
aujourd’hui pour décrire
ce qui serait le successeur
de l’Internet actuel.
Je vous vois venir :
« Mais le métavers,
en quoi ça me concerne ?
J’ai déjà du mal à faire ma déclaration
d’impôts en ligne, c’est bon. »
Pourtant le métavers
concerne tout le monde
et, surtout, peut être bénéfique à tous.
Pour comprendre, il faut que
je vous décrive ce que c’est.
Notez ici que je parle
du métavers au singulier.
C’est parce que je parle
du concept du métavers,
mais en réalité, il n’en existe pas
un seul, mais une multitude.
En gros, on peut le décrire comme
un réseau d’environnements virtuels,
actif en permanence,
où de nombreuses personnes peuvent
se connecter et interagir entre elles.
L’aspect persistant du métavers
est important.
Ces mondes virtuels, si vous ne vous y
connectez pas, ils continuent sans vous.
Un peu comme un jeu vidéo dans lequel
on ne pourrait jamais appuyer sur pause.
Certains d’entre vous sont
peut-être familiers
avec les jeux Second Life
ou World of Warcraft,
qui sont eux-mêmes des formes de métavers.
Moi quand j’étais ado, j’ai passé
pas mal de temps dans un métavers,
peut-être un des moins connus,
qui s’appelait Chimboz.
Ce qui est drôle,
c’est qu’à l’époque, Chimboz,
on n’appelait pas ça du tout un métavers.
C’était plus une sorte
de tchat en ligne évolué.
On pouvait se connecter
à un monde numérique sur l’ordinateur.
Un petit personnage, aussi
appelé Avatar, nous représentait
et on pouvait découvrir
un univers fantastique
tout en discutant avec des inconnus
et en faisant quelques jeux.
C’est difficile de vous décrire
aujourd’hui ce qui m’attirait
dans ce monde alternatif.
Dans la vie réelle, j’étais bien
entourée, d’amis, de ma famille,
mais dans ce monde parallèle,
il y avait une forme de liberté,
celle de parler à des gens
de la France entière
ou juste de s'évader un peu du quotidien.
En fait, quand j’y repense,
je réalise que j’étais quand même
un peu geek à l’époque.
Pourtant, ça m’a pris des années
avant de découvrir que
ma vocation, c’était l’informatique.
Et quelques années de plus
avant de découvrir ce qui allait
devenir le cœur de mes recherches,
la réalité virtuelle.
Ce qui est amusant,
c’est que, si on entend
beaucoup parler du métavers,
c’est notamment lié
à la réalité virtuelle.
Pas parce que c’est nouveau,
car elle date des années 70,
mais grâce à sa démocratisation,
avec des casques de réalité virtuelle
parfois moins chers
que certains smartphones.
C’est aussi à cause du coup marketing
d’une marque ayant
récemment changé de nom,
on ne va pas se mentir.
Mais alors, qu’est-ce qu’elle apporte
au métavers la réalité virtuelle ?
Parce que le métavers,
on peut l’utiliser sans cette technologie.
On peut s’y connecter grâce
à un ordinateur, un smartphone,
s’y déplacer avec le clavier.
Mais lorsque vous enfilez
un casque de réalité virtuelle,
ce monde que vous regardiez
sur votre écran,
vous pouvez maintenant
être totalement immergé dedans.
Et cet avatar qui vous représentait,
vous pouvez désormais
faire corps avec lui.
Et pour cette raison, les avatars sont
un enjeu très important dans le métavers.
Je ne sais pas
si vous aimez vous déguiser,
mais moi, vous l’aurez compris,
j’adore mettre des costumes.
Eh bien, on peut voir le métavers
comme une grande pièce de théâtre
où chacun porte le costume qu'il souhaite.
Que l’on veuille un avatar féminin,
masculin, jeune, vieux, humain ou pas,
tout est possible.
Et pour certains,
c’est une vraie libération
de pouvoir choisir une apparence
au plus proche de leur identité
et de pouvoir interagir dans un contexte
où ils seraient plus en phase
avec eux-mêmes.
Pour d’autres, il s’agit d’une opportunité
pour dépasser ses limites personnelles,
comme la timidité.
Moi-même, je suis plutôt timide
lorsque je parle face à un public.
Si je vous parlais là à travers un avatar,
je pourrais en profiter
pour cacher mes tics de nervosité,
estomper - pourquoi pas ? - mes cernes
et afficher un grand sourire.
Non, heureusement,
je n’ai pas besoin d’avatar pour ça.
Mais ce n'est pas tout.
Les avatars permettent de faire des
choses fascinantes en réalité virtuelle
et notamment de vivre des choses
qu’il ne serait pas possible
de vivre dans le monde réel.
Par exemple, dans mes recherches,
j’ai réalisé une expérience où j’ai mis
deux personnes dans un même avatar.
C’est comme si vous partagiez
votre corps avec quelqu’un d’autre.
Et grâce à ça,
j’ai découvert que lorsqu’un utilisateur
voit ses bras virtuels bouger
alors que c’est l’autre
utilisateur qui les contrôle,
il peut quand même avoir l’impression
d’être à l’origine du mouvement.
Et ça c’est vraiment intéressant pour
de la formation à des gestes techniques
ou de la rééducation motrice.
En effet, que ce soit
dans la formation ou dans le médical,
le métavers peut avoir
des bénéfices conséquents.
Un autre exemple.
Mon père était médecin urgentiste.
C’est une profession où
on voit des cas très différents
et où on peut faire face
à des situations très stressantes.
Dans ce contexte, grâce
à des scénarios variés et rejouables,
la réalité virtuelle permet des formations
et des mises en situation réalistes,
beaucoup moins coûteuses et compliquées.
Il y a aussi beaucoup d’applications
dans le cadre de thérapies médicales
et psychologiques.
Pensez qu’aujourd’hui,
une exposition en réalité virtuelle
permet de modifier
le comportement des gens.
Comme dans le traitement
des phobies par exemple,
mais aussi dans le cadre de thérapies pour
des troubles du comportement alimentaire.
On fait se regarder des patients
dans un miroir virtuel
tout en modulant
la morphologie de leur avatar.
Bon.
Cependant,
ces applications sortent un peu de
la vision dominante actuelle du métavers.
En effet, les grands industriels du
domaine envisagent surtout le métavers
pour réaliser des actions
de la vie quotidienne,
notamment des choses
que l’on réalise déjà avec Internet,
comme parler à nos proches
ou réaliser des achats.
Eh oui !
Un aspect important du métavers
est la monétisation,
et non sans surprise lorsqu’on regarde les
grandes entreprises actrices du phénomène.
Dans le genre, un ami a récemment
acheté dans le métavers une licorne.
Pour les connaisseurs, non,
je ne parle pas de start-up,
je parle d’un cheval,
un vrai cheval, avec une corne.
En plus de ça, il se fait de l’argent
grâce à des courses de chevaux virtuelles.
C’est quand même un peu absurde,
même si c’est peut-être mieux que de
vraies courses de chevaux, je ne sais pas.
Mais ce qui est sûr, c’est que
l’aspect commercial du métavers,
s’il en séduit certains, il fait peur
à d’autres, et je comprends.
Moi-même, je ne suis pas fan.
C’est comme si la société de consommation
n’était pas assez importante
qu’il fallait en plus acheter
des choses qui n’existent pas.
Pour autant,
Je pense qu’il ne faut pas rester
sur ce sentiment de peur
et ne pas oublier que le métavers,
on peut en profiter sans pour autant
dépenser de l’argent,
juste pour en apprécier les avantages.
Un autre exemple.
La pandémie a clairement mis en avant
un autre bénéfice du métavers
où, en étant bloqué chez soi, isolé,
on pouvait, en se connectant
à certaines plateformes,
avoir l’impression d’avoir passé
un moment avec nos proches.
Et, ne pouvant voyager
pendant cette période,
j’ai assisté à des conférences
en réalité virtuelle,
me permettant au passage
de faire des économies financières
et de réduire mon empreinte carbone.
Mais en plus,
c’était beaucoup plus immersif qu’avec
de simples appels visio-conférences.
J'ai pu sur ces plateformes croiser par
hasard des chercheurs du monde entier,
faire du bateau virtuel,
boire un apéro virtuel avec des femmes
chercheuses de ma communauté.
En buvant du vrai vin, par contre,
il ne faut pas abuser.
Parce que, oui,
Il y a certaines choses que l’on n’est pas
prêt à perdre en entrant dans le métavers.
Car la réalité virtuelle reste encore
limitée sur certains aspects
et notamment dans les sens
qu’elle stimule.
Ces derniers temps, beaucoup d’entre vous
ont expérimenté la perte de certains sens.
Le goût et l’odorat,
ça doit vous dire quelque chose.
Pas top.
Eh bien, en réalité virtuelle,
c’est un peu pareil.
Il y a des sens qui se perdent.
La vue est très exploitée,
l'ouïe également.
Mais le toucher, le contact,
si présents dans nos vies,
sont beaucoup plus difficiles
à transcrire en réalité virtuelle,
tout comme le goût et l’odorat.
Il y a néanmoins de plus en plus de
recherches qui explorent ces défis.
À l’INRIA Rennes, par exemple,
des chercheurs ont développé un système
qui permet de donner une sensation
tactile cohérente dans la main
lorsque l’on cueille une pomme virtuelle.
Par contre, donner l’impression
de croquer dans la pomme
et faire ressentir son goût,
on en est encore loin.
Mais en fait, ce n’est pas grave.
Le but n’est pas non plus de passer
100% de son temps dans le métavers.
Et si on veut se nourrir, il vaut mieux
manger une vraie pomme, en fait.
Le métavers n’a pas vocation
à remplacer la réalité,
même s’il y a toujours
le risque de certaines dérives.
Pour ça, il y a déjà des chercheurs
qui en explorent les potentielles
conséquences sanitaires,
comme avec les risques d’addiction
ou les effets sur la vision
liés à une exposition prolongée.
Jusqu’à présent, je vous ai surtout
parlé des aspects bénéfiques du métavers,
mais derrière le rideau,
il vient avec son lot de défauts.
Par exemple,
Les avatars anonymisent
totalement les utilisateurs,
comme si tout le monde portait un masque.
Vous vous imaginez sortir, faire vos
courses et tout le monde porte un masque.
Oui, vous avez expérimenté ça
pendant la pandémie,
mais je ne parle pas de celui-là.
Le risque avec ça, c’est que
les gens se sentent tout permis,
pouvant mener à des risques
de harcèlement ou d’arnaque.
Et pour ces raisons, on sait
qu’il y a encore du boulot
avant que le métavers
puisse être bien utilisé.
En fait, on peut dire que si le métavers
est une grande pièce de théâtre,
il reste encore à en écrire les scènes.
C’est en partie le rôle des chercheurs
de se poser les bonnes questions
afin d’aller vers des métavers bénéfiques
pour l’humain, et non nocifs.
Mais c’est aussi le rôle de tous les
citoyens de s’emparer du phénomène,
que ce soit en se familiarisant avec lui,
en en effectuant
une utilisation bienveillante
et pourquoi pas
en contribuant à la recherche,
en participant à des études utilisateurs.
Alors, qu’en pensez-vous ?
Voulez-vous rester spectateur du métavers
ou devenir acteur de son évolution ?
Je vous laisse y réfléchir,
je dois nourrir ma licorne.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)